this is how hard it is to be a man and
it's amazing because Society expects it
of you but so do women if you had a man
be honest you had a man and you went to
your man and said oh I've got this
problem it's I can't fix this it's
broken the car Tire's broken and he went
I don't know you you try up like you'd
be like well [__] what the [__]
point are you that's the truth you can
see her involved we'd call a mechanic no
you wouldn't you'd look at your man and
go what do you mean you can't fix it
yeah this is what she's saying about
your man will get up and go and you know
what's beautiful about math journey a
bunch of times a man will go up and he
doesn't have a clue how to fix it
himself but he'll go don't worry baby
okay and he'll stand up with no money
and no clue and he'll go out there and
[__] try and find a way because
there's a man you need to be useful it
is so difficult to be a man you have no
idea the amount of pressure that we're
under from society and from the women we
even want to associate with on a whole
it's difficult just to keep all these
things in mind it's hard